[Musique]
le temps du secret bancaire est révolu
depuis le printemps dernier 381
journalistes du monde entier fouilles
dans une base de données qui contient
plus de 13 millions de documents très
secret on y retrouve notamment des
informations sur des entreprises de chez
nous qui profitent des paradis fiscaux
plusieurs collègues de l'équipe d'
enquêtes ont fouillé trois histoires
dont celle tout à fait surprenante d'un
revendeur de billets de spectacles un
scalpel si vous préférez ou je te goures
wade du pouvoir est déjà au canada
andrew albicy gino art elle nous raconte
cette histoire d'un jeune québécois
devenus millionnaires aux dépens des
fans
[Musique]
il y a environ trois ans on a vu
apparaître une série de noms du canada
particulièrement de la région de
boucherville qui ramassait des billets à
londres aurait droit que l'anc est
depuis longtemps sur les revendeurs de
billets dans l'industrie du spectacle
parmi ses plus importantes cibles se
trouvent un québécois simon a vu son nom
pour des concerts d'être chez orange
brique metallica je crois qu'ils
manipulent le marché ce qui nous manque
[Musique]
je me disais tiens c'est étrange voilà
ce gars du canada qui achètent des
centaines de billets pour chaque
spectacle intéressant admob dirige un
groupe qui mène campagne en grande
bretagne contre les revendeurs à grande
échelle qui je me demandais pourquoi
cette personne du québec achète tant de
billets pour des spectacles en
angleterre ce jeune québécois de 30 ans
c'est jules hié la vallée en novembre
2016 il fait la manchette dans les
médias britanniques
après quoi il deviendra plus discret
dans le cas de julien la vallée il fait
beaucoup d'argent en revendant ses
vielles au royaume uni l'histoire fait
partie des exemples cités devant un
comité spécial des communes britannique
sur la vente abusive de billets les
détails de son entreprise ont cessé
d'apparaître sur les sites du moment il
a été révélé qu'il opérait à partir du
québec
mais c'est bien et est toujours en vente
celle qui dénonçait julien la vallée
devant les parlementaires dirige la
music managers forum qui regroupe plus
de 500 agents et producteurs de
l'industrie de la musique britannique
notre objectif c'est d'aider les
artistes qui veulent que leurs billets
se rendent directement à leurs fans pas
à des revendeurs industriels
on dit que le marché mondial de l'art
ventes vont maintenant plus que toute
l'industrie du disque les milliards de
dollars l'agent du groupe britannique
man fridenson est lui aussi engagé dans
cette chasse aux revendeurs qu'il
qualifie de parasites pour les fans
les fans se font avoir je trouve ça
audio je crois qu'à un moment donné ils
vont se réveiller et faire entendre leur
mécontentement
[Applaudissements]
pire qu'on ait vu jusqu'à maintenant
julien la vallée est dans la mire de
reggie worker un consultant en sécurité
we propose on fournit des services aux
producteurs et aux artistes
where we examen ça on vérifie les ventes
pour s'assurer que les systèmes de
billetterie ne sont pas attaqués par des
revendeurs dans son travail
re doit que voit directement l'effet des
revendeurs lorsqu'ils font disparaître
des milliers de billets de l'inventaire
peu de temps après la mise en vente 200
il veut trouver s'ils mettent la main
sur dix mille billets et bien c'est dix
mille fans qui ne pourront pas les
acheter au prix de patrice parler
tous ces billets apparaissent ensuite
rapidement sur les sites de revente à
prix nettement supérieur
d'ailleurs les paradise peppers nous
permettent une incursion dans les
affaires de juliet la vallée en 2015
il fait enregistrer la compagnie à wall
street à l'île de man considéré par
plusieurs comme un paradis fiscal
ce document de la fuite nous apprend
qu'il visait déjà alors des marges de
profit de 35 à 40% sur ces reventes au
royaume uni this is très intéressant
sept autres documents nous révèle le
chiffre d'affaires d'une compagnie à
numéro qu'il détient au québec près de 7
millions de dollars en 2013 près de 8
millions en 2014
c'est vraiment beaucoup d'argent nos
collègues de la sib ici ont par ailleurs
obtenu des documents qui décrivent
l'achat de plus de 300 billets en
quelques minutes à peine pour la tournée
2016 de la chanteuse adele alors que la
limite d'achat de billets par personne
est fixé à 4 on retrouve les noms de
julien la vallée et de certains de ses
proches avec de multiples adresses
différentes au canada et aux états unis
julien la vallée est une menace aux
billetteries
dans tout pays où il ya une industrie
musicale en santé à ims touch
après des années à suivre les activités
de julien navale et qui a notamment
revendu ses billets sur le site de la
compagnie stobbe rob roy soupçonne qu'il
contrevient aux lois britanniques sur la
protection des consommateurs john dalli
n'a aucune façon légale de ramasser des
billets comme ça en prétendant être
plusieurs consommateurs à la fois quand
vous agissez comme une entreprise
on parle d'une affaire de plusieurs
millions de dollars ici pourquoi
personne n'en qu'elle a sombré vastine
et les revendeurs font aussi des
affaires d'or chez nous une recherche
rapide sur stop au bac il ya quelques
jours le démontre pour aller voir pink
au centre bell en mars prochain
vous devrez payer jusqu'à 1000 2000 et
même 3000 $ si vous voulez j'ai une
place devant la scène les artistes
québécois n'échappe pas aux revendeurs
en terminant je tiens à vous dire que
j'ai fait ce spectacle si dans plusieurs
villes et que jusqu'à maintenant jamais
j'ai senti un accueil aussi chaleureux
aussi intense ici aussi tout comme nos
biens en vente des centaines voire des
milliers de billets je n'ai pas compté
son sur six est là et oddo b aux tripes
du prix et personnellement bon mes
billets sont vendus je trouve ça triste
pour le consommateur pour le fun les
billets de la nouvelle tournée de martin
matte se vendent bien plus de 50000 se
sont vendus dès la première journée
il est coproducteur de son spectacle et
a donc son mot à dire sur le prix de ses
billets bonjour à mes billets rapidement
j'ai cette chance le à un prix disons
concurrentielle entre compris qu'on juge
équitable puis ça fonctionne parce qu'on
va rapidement oublié mais il n'a aucun
contrôle sur ce qu'ils revendent ces
billets à fort prix sur des plateformes
comme billets.ca j'ai vu aujourd'hui dis
bien pour mon choix québec 220 dans
l'arche
ça n'a aucun sens de la raison pour
laquelle je veux être ici aujourd'hui
c'est ça c'est dire ok ya une loi elle
est pas du tout respecté
d'ailleurs qui sont ces mystérieux
revendeurs qui ont des billets
même pour plusieurs dates qui affiche
pourtant complet martin matte nom n'a
aucune idée est-ce que vous même comme
producteur vous avez quelconque entente
de convenu avec quelconque revendeur yo
ma mère une fois la queue vendu de vie
n'a aucunement aucunement absolument
aucunement sexy
c'est aberrant nous on vend nos billets
donc aucun revendeur qui nous contactent
parce que c'est sûr que ce serait un
refus total on veut vendre nos billets à
prix compétitifs pour les gens dont on a
aucune entente avec personne souvent les
gens qui achètent sur ce site la sapo
vraiment que c'est un site de revente et
le problème c'est que la personne qui
pense que moi je vends mon billet
sapience arrive à mon spectacle en avant
avec une attitude de jos pense à mon
sens pièce ça vaut pour janvier après
une sortie de louis josé houde lors du
gala de l'adisq la loi sur la protection
du consommateur avait pourtant été
modifié depuis 2012 un commerçant qui
fait la revente de billets doit
respecter plusieurs exigences
cette législation l'a effacé la
contourne les sites web qui faisait de
la revente maintenant sont transformés
en plateforme
ce ne sont pas elles qui revendent et s
exonère absolument de toutes les
obligations de la loi en étant
simplement un intermédiaire sur
billets.ca par exemple on ne fait que
vous rappelez dans cette case qu'il y a
des règles à respecter si vous vous
déclarez commerçants les personnes qui
en font leur métier il que de racheter
et de vente des billets
et il se déclare pas comme entreprise
ils disent qu'ils le font
individuellement mais achètent des
dizaines et des dizaines de billets
difficile de savoir qui sont ces
revendeurs sur billets.ca car la
confidentialité est primordiale écrit
ton sur le site
plus loin on lit nous nous appuyons sur
un réseau étendu de revendeurs de
billets provenant de partout en amérique
du nord
c'est en un réseau de revendeurs partout
en amérique du nord sarsan - des
individus qu'à des entreprises
dans le système actuel il n'y a pas du
tout de transparence sur le marché
secondaire
moi je pense qu'une évidence de revoir
la loi va voir ce qui fonctionne pas ce
pourquoi les contourner j'ai trouvé des
moyens rang égal de révoquer voici ce
qu'ils font pour la contourner en
l'adaptant donne des armes en beaucoup
plus costaud il ya quelque chose qu'il
faut que souhaite dissuasif en grande
bretagne en plus d'améliorer les lois
les autorités ont multiplié leur enquête
les entreprises de revente comme celle
de julien la vallée à wall street ont
d'ailleurs dû s'adapter en affichant le
prix d'origine de leurs billets
on ne sait cependant pas comme en
afrique et a pu se procurer autant de
billets la compagnie a récemment annoncé
sa dissolution
il y à une amélioration le bureau de la
concurrence inspectent davantage les
compagnes et de revente pour qu'elles
respectent les lois
curieux tout de même que les affaires de
julien la vallée soit connue en
angleterre mais que ce gros revendeur
demeure à peu près invisible au québec
où il possède tout de même qu'une
compagnie à numéro est un site web tic
et aria les documents contenus dans les
paroisses peppers indique d'ailleurs
clairement qu'ils achètent et revendent
des billets aussi au canada
le vous montre un document sur lequel
vous en rendez vous au québec couci
couça envoyer un courriel ou les reçus
oui mais on a plein d'autres questions
pourraient par exemple nous disiez pas
si accompagné numérotée la même
casquette arrière pascaline pas vous
avez seulement à contacter l'info vous
répondre à vos questions
nous avons donc écrit alain faucher tic
et à rien points comme la réponse est
venue de l'avocat de l'entreprise
il précise que tic et arias ne peut
accorder d'entrevue sur la nature de ces
transactions ou de ses liens d'affaires
pour des raisons liées à la
compétitivité de son industrie
chiquita rien considère qu'elle réalise
toutes ses activités en conformité avec
les lois et règles des juridictions dans
lesquelles nos pères et effectue ses
ventes
pef vous assurez d'adapter nous nous loi
pour pouvoir protéger les droits des
gens à québec la ministre responsable de
la loi sur la protection du consommateur
se dit prête à intervenir
à la lumière de ce que vous me dites à
la lumière des commentaires qui sont
entendus si on a trouvé le moyen de
contourner la loi
on n'aura pas d'autre choix que de
travailler avec le milieu travailler
avec ma collègue le ministre de la
culture pour faire un saut de revoir la
loi
soyons aussi intelligent que ces gens là
qui contourne la loi expire en août et
des lois qui sont plus efficaces et plus
aguerris que celle qu'on nomme l'ontario
par exemple a déposé le mois dernier un
projet de loi qui obligera notamment les
revendeurs par internet a indiqué la
valeur d'origine du billet
la loi interdira aussi l'utilisation de
logiciels qui servent à contourner les
limites d'achat de billets enfin le coût
des billets ne pourra plus être majoré
de plus de 50% du prix de base
si nous pouvons et nous devons aller
aussi loin que l'ontario on le fera puis
si on peut elle n'est peut-être plus
loin on pourrait le faire aussi
[Musique]
à londres le joueur que continuent de
surveiller les activités de julien la
vallée il souhaite aussi que les
autorités au canada enquête à son sujet
aux autres je souhaiterais qu'ils
empiètent de manière approfondie selon
lui cependant le temps presse et les
autorités devront agir avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard et ça devient de plus en
plus difficile de repérer ces tentatives
d'achat de billets ces méthodes sont
plus sophistiqués et bientôt nous
pourrions perdre sa trace
[Musique]
gino vous nous avez parlé de billets.ca
dans votre enquête commun répondent
évidemment on aurait voulu avoir plus de
précisions sur leur mode de
fonctionnement on l'a laissé plusieurs
messages téléphoniques par courriel mais
tout ça est restée sans réponse mais
parlante de courriels on en aura
certains très révélateur après la pause
on se demande est ce que le canada veut
vraiment lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux
[Musique]